(upbeat music)
- It's Academy Award season which means
that all of Hollywood is buzzing
about that famous golden guy, Oscar.
And this year there's
more reason than ever
to want to get your hands on
one of the coveted statuettes.
For the first time in 50
years, Oscar will have a penis.
Meet Heinrich Baronowski,
a man who has spent his life with Oscar.
In 1929, his father handcrafted
the first ever Oscar statuette.
As soon as he was old enough,
Heinrich began sculpting
the statues himself.
Stan, what would you say your
grandfather's specialty is?
- (foreign language)
- No doubt, it's the penis.
- Penis.
- The lines of the penis,
the shape of the penis,
the shining of the penis.
The penis is his passion, his pride.
It's his everything.
(chuckling)
- [Host] From 1929 to 1950,
every Oscar was crafted
in the Baronowski style,
complete with a tiny penis.
- As you can see here,
this is a droopier-
- (foreign language)
- European style penis.
From around 1933.
- [Host] Mhmm.
- (foreign language)
- Oh, this Oscar, which is from 1938,
has a corkscrew penis.
- Okay.
- (foreign language)
- Spun. Corkscrew. Yeah.
- Spun penis.
- Of course, yeah.
- Oh and this is a very rare Oscar
with a stiff erect penis.
- Wow.
Which was only made for
one year and that was 1945.
- To celebrate the end of World War II?
- (foreign language)
- No.
- [Host] Sadly, in 1950
Heinrich began to suffer
from arthritis, making it
difficult for him to perform
the precise delicate movements
necessary for sculpting
Oscar's detailed penis.
- (foreign language)
- He says with his dexterity gone
it was difficult to craft the penis.
- (foreign language)
- Oh, he said, dick-sterity.
- [Host] For years, it
seemed as though the world
would never again see Oscar's genitals.
But all that changed earlier this year
when Heinrich underwent an
experimental hand transplant.
With the new hand, Heinrich
could once again return
to the penis sculpting he loved.
The Academy took notice and last winter
Heinrich got the call
he'd been waiting for.
- (foreign language)
- He said to me, hello are you
the sculptor of Oscar penis?
- (foreign language)
- And I said, yes. Yes, I make
the penis for the golden man.
- (foreign language)
- And then they asked me to come back.
(foreign language)
Sorry.
- (foreign language)
- If he could make small
golden penises all day long
and into the night for
the rest of his days,
he would die happy.
- I hope you do die that way.
I want you to die
that way.
- Thank you.
Heinrich, Stan, thank you both so much
for joining us.
And for Entertainment
Spotlight, I'm Kay Donnely.
(upbeat music)